[Music]
just in case you needed another reason
to love tom holland he just delivered
making good on a special promise to a
little boy in wyoming you ready yeah
you're gonna love this last year tom
reached out to then six-year-old bridger
walker after his own heroic story went
viral see bridger saved his younger
sister from a dog attack he jumped in
front of a charging german shepherd
resulting in over 90 stitches in his
head and face at the time marvel stars
like chris evans mark ruffalo chris
hemsworth brie larson and more all sent
bridger videos and well wishes praising
him for his bravery i'm sure you've
heard a lot of this over the last couple
days but let me be the next one to tell
you
how
you're a hero and tom well he called
bridger personally offering him a chance
to come and hang out on the set of
spider-man no way home you heard it here
on e.t
and turns out the 25-year-old marvel
star kept his promise because bridger's
dad robert walker recently shared some
pretty sweet clips of his little boy
flying high with peter parker in full
spider-man costume
[Music]
robert posted that clip to instagram
along with a series of pics and a
lengthy caption thanking tom for making
the whole thing happen kids it's so nice
to be able to put a smile on their face
he also praised tom zendaya and the cast
for making his kids quote feel like
stars quote they don't just act the part
of friendly neighborhood heroes that's
what they truly are robert added that
he'll quote never forget the grace and
kindness that tom and zendaya showed the
family
zendaya immediately approached my
teenage daughter and told her how much
she loved her nails i don't know if she
will ever know how much that simple act
means to me to see my sweet daughter
light up with self-confidence and joy i
feel very lucky and honored robert also
thanked tom's brother harry holland for
being their personal guide for the day
before explaining that while there are
many reasons to love the movie for him
it's all about the cast and crew who he
says are quote good kind and passionate
people individuals who heard about a
little boy's injury who wanted to make
it right robert wrapped up his post by
writing quote people who are willing to
stop a very busy day of shooting to make
my little boy smile and give him a
chance to web sling with his hero
and while spider-man no way home is the
final flick in this trilogy it looks
like tom might not be hanging up his
suit for good just yet a fun little
twist according to producer amy pascal
at least three more spider-man movies
that would involve both tom and the
marvel cinematic universe are in
development something the president of
marvel studios echoed to et at the
premiere earlier this month we love tom
holland we think he's uh he's an amazing
amazing no pun intended spider-man and
we are starting amy and i starting to
work uh with marvel studios and sony on
what the next story could be uh and we
certainly want that to be with tom
holland as for tom he told et he's down
well that's great news that's awesome
kevin is he's he's the king amy is the
queen uh they're like my parents i love
them to bits and if they'll have me back
i'll be there